there's brand new news out that's
citadel one of the largest financial
firms in the world is getting into
bitcoin and cryptocurrencies but they're
not just buying it and they're not just
trading it they think that they can
actually compete with all of the
exchanges the news broke this morning
that citadel is teaming up with virtue
sequoia and paradigm they want to create
some sort of brand new crypto trading
marketplace now of course within the
article they describe it's not really an
exchange they describe it as a better
mousetrap they want to take on the
exchanges the reason being that the
current crypto market structure is
deficient and inhibits wider adoption
from a lot of investors but it's
absolutely laugh out loud funny that ken
griffin and citadel are now getting into
bitcoin and cryptocurrency why well
remember just a couple of months ago
when he said that it literally was a
jihadist call against the dollar now ken
griffin's a really smart guy he's a
multi-billionaire and he's built a great
firm but of course this idea of calling
bitcoin or crypto a jihadist call
against the dollar it was just him
talking his book now all of a sudden he
realizes that he can make a lot of money
in this brand new industry and once he
figured out how to make money it's no
longer a jihadist call now he thinks
that he can come in and save it it's
kind of like when the government says
the government is here and we are here
to help of course citadel they know a
lot about financial infrastructure they
know a lot about investing they know a
lot about financial markets but can they
actually beat the technologists at their
game that remains to be seen there's
this great quote that ken had previously
where he stated what a crazy concept
this is that we are a country embracing
so many bright young talented people to
come up with a replacement for our
reserve currency
now of course that's exactly what it
ends up being it's a talent war will the
centralized large incumbent institutions
like citadel and others get all the
talent or will the talent have the
backbone to stand up to the incumbents
will they go and build the decentralized
system there's only two choices you can
join the legacy system or you can build
a new one that new one's gaining
momentum so over 150 million people
around the world that have adopted the
digital currency and it continues to
accelerate citadel ken griffin and other
incumbent firms they're going to have a
choice either stand by and stay in the
legacy system and be disrupted or go
ahead and capitulate get rid of all the
jihadist talk and join the future